this is a level 83 pepper panic saga
walkthrough video I'm going to play the
level and complete it and try to walk
you through the thought process this is
a difficult level for a couple reasons
there's only 15 moves and there's a very
small 4 by 4 space in the middle in
which you have to make matches destroy
the ice and then get to the statues and
the statues are all completely intact
which means they take three hits each in
the beginning we can see we have green
blue and red trapped in the ice and it
sort of works like you want to make the
big matches first to make direct damage
and grow peppers and if you can't get
those and you want to grow the colors
that are trapped in the ice it's you
know you're not going to be able to
totally break them free that way you'll
run out of moves but at least you can do
something productive whatever like right
now I don't have any gaps actually have
a pretty bad center because all the
colors are in there and they're not
really arranged in a way that I can use
them so I'm going to match these greens
on the outside to drop some new ones
down and
this is pretty pretty bad because now we
have to waste another move just to do
that I'm going to match the blue this
way that'll bring another red one now
now we can match the red and yell at the
same time and at least clear some space
again not much in the way of help but if
you watch how these things fall around
the corner you can see that you know
making a match next to this actually
brought that one down so that we can
make em for cut the match now and this
will just be to get this out of the way
that's not one of our trapped colors so
it doesn't really help but those being
in the way actually getting rid of them
is worth it so this is what we're
looking for something like this a for
pepper match it's going to hit the ice
in we're going to grow that pepper
the yellower also just in the way so
just when you're when you're making
matches in the middle just try to look
at where you can you know make one that
will match to if you can because that
way you won't waste move all right this
is a missile shoot a shockwave down
let's close this blue pepper and hit
this one so that'll be good
and now we have the blue set up or we
can we can start a panic and a mover to
the fastest way to do it
the fastest way would be to make this
match and then make this match or make
this match but I'd also like to clear
this I so I'm going to match these three
green first and then you got a little
bit lucky here I'm going to do this
instead all right now this is that this
tea will actually this should get it
going it'll I don't know if we'll
complete the level in one move but
that's our best hope
dragon
are the summary of green yellow blue and
red so all the colors are trapped in the
ice
so in that case you know I'm just going
to make a move lower down whenever I
don't have big combos if I match this
yellow here it'll match the red too so
I'll go ahead and do that
red and blue all right we got ourselves
t will make the T got some of the ice
gone now that's these this red one it
will drop the green and explore the
green as well you know that's just a
clear space more than anything here we
have a choice thing for 24 pepper
matches one going up down on one going
side to side I'd always pick the one go
inside the side because this stuff down
here tends to clear itself out and we
you know we just need to try to click
you know concern moves as much as
possible
alright so the green is the furthest
along that we don't have any green left
in the middle of a match it would be
nice to set something up do one of these
three matches due to set something up
but that really wasn't anything
this is a this is a strange spot because
usually a five pepper match is a really
good thing but if we if we match this
we're going to have one two three four
five there's only a few yellow other
yellow peppers on the board but we can't
get to anything else I think I'm going
to do it just to clear the space more
than anything all right so yeah that you
see all that yellow is gone now now we
have a four pepper that will go that way
and you can see how much different it
makes it when the ice is gone you know
you really you know you really need to
get the ice out of there so that you can
make these bigger matches
and it's usually one of those things
where it's you can usually get rid of
the ice or you know start a panic but
it's hard to get both going at the same
time so now we have four four moves left
we can't really met if we match these
yellows it's not really going to lead to
a pepper panic if we hit this one here
it'll get us there in two moves because
it'll make this one stage five I think
this is our best match over here because
it all
it will get that one to stage 5 right
now
I'm just trying to decide if i want to
set off the red or i'm pretty sure if I
explode the yellows that means that
they're going to these ones are going to
slide away from that statue anyway so i
won't get the hit so we're gonna have to
go this way plus we already wasted that
move matching that one down there less
will stick with our plan it looks like
it did a pretty good job
alright that's a pretty good outcome
okay so let's look at the board we have
if we make this tea right here we will
hit the statue with it first and
foremost post will start another chain
reaction the yellow pepper here may drop
and hit both of other statues but I'm
not sure honestly because these two
might drop at the same time let's see
what happens SE the two on the side jobs
first but this will get us our statute
anyway so so that's how you do it you
know took a couple tries it's going to
you know there's no there's nothing that
I can tell you that it's going to make
sure that you can get it every time you
know you're going to have to just make
the best decisions on a regular basis
and it eventually work out